martin biron alec castonguay christian
dufour bonsoir bonsoir ça tombe bien
christian il ya votre texte matin dans
la presse qui résume plus que vous nous
dites ici depuis quelques semaines vous
en avez marre qu'on s'en prenne à ceux
qui ont envie d'un peu d'air et tout ça
vous dit faut faire la différence entre
l'écran peut tisser des gens qui veulent
vivre
je vais vous faire entendre ça va
sûrement pas vous calmer l'extrait dr
arruda dit nous les restos on avait
peut-être été d'accord qu'on les laisse
ouvert dans certaines circonstances on
écoute notamment les musées ou les ou
les restaurants nous avions recommandé
que ça pouvait pour potentiellement
restés ouverts
compte tenu qu'on n'avait pas démontré
que les gens respecté les consignes et
cetera mais dans une question des
proches voudraient perceptuelle de
fermer les rassemblements la maison puis
laisser des zones où il ya des
rassemblements gouvernement pris une
autre décision
donc les restaurants vie sans savoir
donner garder au vin se sont à dire dans
les scénarios que nous avions fait il y
avait un scénario où les restaurants
privés
pouvait rester ouvert un christian je
vous donne la parole
ça me semble majeur parce que la
fermeture des restaurants
ça a été un drame économique pour ces
établissements à l'ock qui avait fait
des efforts considérables pour s'adapter
et dans la mesure où on parlait de
soupape pour que les gens continuent à
observer les consignes c'était en
l'encadrant que c'est une décision
gouvernementale
par souci de cohérence c'est que dans
les hypothèses de la santé publique
comme dans d'autres pays aussi il y
avait la possibilité qui restera reste
ouvert dans la mesure où c'était la
bulle familiale
il me semble que le gouvernement va être
beaucoup sur la défensive là dessus on
touche à quelque chose de très important
oui avec une décision bien sûr le goût
l'a dit à plusieurs reprises à la fin de
la journée et comme on dit c'est moi qui
décide
mais là les restaurateurs vont pas la
trouver drôle et les gens et les clients
devraient agir aussi ça dépend à quel
moment de l'épidémie on part au tout
début de la deuxième vague y avait
peut-être effectivement une possibilité
de garder ouvert un peu plus longtemps
ce niveau mais mylène droit indien
moment donné la directrice les gens de
la santé publique de montréal a
peut-être qu'on pourrait revenir les
ouvrez des s'est rendu compte très
rapidement que les chiffres étaient
palop que c'était impossible
tous les endroits qu'ils avaient le
restaurant ouvert dans le monde
ils sont fermés à peu près maintenant
c'est le c'est vrai en allemagne c'est
vrai j'ai une canne et en alberta elle
vient de les fermer
il était ouvert donc ce n'est pas à quel
moment on parle de l'épidémie
actuellement avec les chiffres qu'on y
seraient fermés les restaurants de toute
façon à ce qu'ils auraient pu rester
ouverts une semaine deux semaines trois
semaines de plus peut-être mais le
gouvernement voulait envoyer ce moment
là un message que tous les
rassemblements sociaux devait être
diminuée alors si vous avez pas le droit
de recevoir un couple d'amis à la maison
mais vous pouvez aller manger au
restaurant avec eux à moins de deux
mètres à la même table ont trouvé qu'il
y avait une incohérence dans le message
gouvernemental et donc on est allé plus
loin que ce que la santé publique
recommande et c'est pas la première fois
les écoles primaires à montréal à la fin
du mois de mai la santé publique avait
dit vous pouvez les ouvrir sécuritaire
le gouvernement dit je vous parlais pas
d'acceptabilité sociale les classes sont
pas prêtes
ça va être compliqué on repousse à
l'automne il est arrivé des fois où le
gouvernement n'était pas d'accord avec
la santé publique généralement pour
faire plus qu'est ce que la santé
publique recommande oui mais martin ya
des gens qui vont dire on comprend
qu'ils en ont fait plus
très bien mais soute avec l argumentaire
avec quelles bases scientifiques on veut
en faire plus par souci de cohérence
plaide alex est ce que le gouvernement
le premier ministre va devoir faire
beaucoup de pédagogie donne elle pour
expliquer un peu le raisonnement qui est
derrière les décisions que le
gouvernement a pris mais c'est pas blanc
et noirs
et c'est compliqué il faut comprendre
aussi que le niveau les restaurateurs et
les gens qui sont fermés présentement
son s'user normes pression ils sont ça
fait deux fois qu'on les ferme et là il
voit noël passé c'est une période que ce
serait difficile pour eux et je dirais
qu'après le témoignage de monsieur
arruda sur twitter l'aca s'est enflammée
directement et c'est normal parce que la
pression et les fortes alors le
gouvernement a expliqué pourquoi il a
pris cette décision là il peut être
qu'on va avoir plus d'éléments de
réponse mais c'est sûr que pour les
entrepreneurs c'est très difficile
surtout qu'on parle de confiner
davantage web encore de confiner
davantage justement jo faire entendre
monsieur legault alors la question était
lui était reposé aujourd'hui pensez vous
vraiment reconfirmer comme au printemps
voici sa réponse
la réponse est entre les mains des
québécois si on continue d'avoir une
minorité de personnes qui respectent pas
les mesures qui respectent pas les deux
mains qui portent pas toujours la masse
d'un centre d'achat ben on n'aura pas le
choix que de regarder des scénarios par
exemple fermer les commerces non
essentiel pendant la période de noël
alors ça dépend des québécois dit-il
christian on sent dans ses positions
une très grande possibilité qu'on
confirme de soins de noël et ça peut se
défendre parce que ce n'est plus vrai
que d'activités économiques et 13 au
ralenti durant cette période là encore
que il ya certains métiers du disque de
soi ne s'est pas assis faudrait refermer
un mois peut-être que le gouvernement il
est à l'annoncer maintenant de peur de
se demander pourquoi vous ne fermez pas
tout de suite qu'à fermer pour qu'on
dirait que les gens observent les
consignes c'est vrai ou que les gens
observent des conseils il les observe
quand même pas
mais moi je suis pas devin mais je n'ai
pas su retrouver deux semaines les
indicatifs en fait vont vers ce jeu suit
pas ce qu'en pense avec cuba on a plutôt
moi j'ai enfin j'ai plutôt l'impression
inverse que monsieur legault voudrais
inviter de d'ajouter une autre couche la
wii pour un peu continuer la discussion
sur les restaurateurs c'est la même
chose pour ceux qui ont des petits
commerces puis qu'il veut les garder
ouverts puis qu'espère d'avoir un peu
d'achalandage dans les fameuses semaine
de boxing day qui vont arriver en même
temps en épidémiologie là c'est assez
simple si on ne change pas les consignes
on ne peut pas voir d'amélioration de la
situation sanitaire sanitaire donc
espérer que les chiffres actuels baisse
un peu par magie en ne changeant rien
c'est un peu effectivement de la pensée
magique il faudra qu'il se passe quelque
chose si on veut faire baisser les
chiffres actuels est-ce que ce sera
suffisant de fermer les écoles
peut-être ça va effectivement diminuer
la pression le fait qu'ils aient
beaucoup d'entreprises manufacturières
entre autres qu'ils soient fermés dans
le temps des fêtes ça va aider aussi est
ce que ce sera trop tard est ce qu'on
est capable de se rendre jusque là c'est
un peu ce que le gouvernement tenterait
une supposée il est ce que cette période
d'accalmie la wii elle va nous aider
suffisamment on le sait pas qui est ce
qu'on est capable de faire encore deux
semaines avant d'arriver à cette période
d'accalmie là où c'est faudra peut-être
avant commencé à restreindre davantage
par exemple l'accès à certains commerces
martin monsieur legault choisi ses mots
la semaine dernière y est obligé de
remettre la pâte à dents dans le cube
alors il va il va éviter de se retrouver
dans la même situation il vaut garder
ses portes ouvertes
il ya eu un caucus des députés hier soir
et les échos que j'en ai c'est que
c'était très partagés il y en a qui
pensaient pour devait confinés pendant
toute la période des fêtes et d'autres
non l'impression qu'on a effectivement
c'est que monsieur legault aimerait
donner un peu d'air et d'ailleurs il y
envoie différents signaux la salle dite
les écoles vont être fermées donc on
peut comprendre que les enfants seront
dans leur famille relativement confiné
et aujourd'hui talent un petit peu plus
loin dans sa demande
aux entrepreneurs il leur a dit il
aurait de mieux deux jours y avait dit
j'aimerais ça que voulez vous mettiez
vos employés en télétravail mais
aujourd'hui a dit j'aimerais ça si vous
pouviez fermé durant la période des
fêtes
alors il avance un peu ils essayent de
confiner partiellement mais c'est
certain que si les gens vont tous dans
les centres commerciaux pour par sa
période des fêtes ne sont pas plus
avancés mais idéalement et si les gens
respectent les consignes peut-être que
les commerces pourraient rester ouverts
ce serait plus simple bon mais encore
une fois des décisions qui doivent être
basées sur des recommandations de la
santé publique
puis paul l'intuition des députés du
caucus la partie parce que christian y
avait une phrase qui m'a fait rire dans
votre papier ce matin odier il ya
beaucoup de gens qui qui deviennent des
experts le genou mais la dalle tous les
années laisse les journalistes
maintenant on voit un twitter vers 110
ha long la question n'est pas en tirer
ça c'est sûr ça va être ça les
certitudes n'ya pas grave on qu'un non
là je fait accompli mas latrie siens oui
oui j'ai donné ordre à baisser salle on
a compris quelque chose puis de soins
d'après ian données qui contredisent
aussi de tous les pays acp ue des pays
où ça allait bien un moment donné presse
avons pu bien maintenant et le conte a
donc c'est quand qu'on n'est pas juste
dans la science il faut qu'une base
notre spip
il ya aussi un point politique sur vous
a fait ressortir
donc c'est qu'on n'est pas dans le blanc
des vaccinations c'est quand même faut
le souligner aujourd'hui on le voit
d'ici la fin de l'année on devrait
pouvoir avoir vacciné tous ceux qui le
voudraient 100 % de la population c'est
pas les doses en ruine ses 125 mille
personnes au mois de décembre 3 millions
de janvier à mars 15 à 20 millions avril
à juin et 38 millions juillet à
septembre sur deux files on nous a collé
le 2e christian vous donnez loin
la liste on est le deuxième on a
approuvé avant les américains
le fameux vaccin je tiens à dire patrice
parce que j'ai reçu des courriels très
méchante je sais pas pour vous souhaiter
qu est ce qui manque et du bac c'est
lary froid moi je ne demande pas mieux
que de me tromper de m'être trompé
totalement parce que je les veux les
bacs très haut plutôt que tant mieux les
pressions au fait que le nôtre
gouvernement fédéral est plus efficace
que prévu jeudi sur le tour de table a
tué avec le vaccin approuvé aujourd'hui
par le canada c'est quand même un jalon
important
ouais je pense qu'on était trop content
aussi de cause du côté de santé canada
d'être 24 heures au val bas et vidéo aux
etats unis la de pouvoir direct et nous
aussi on avait le même processus
accéléré des gens en place on étudie les
mêmes donné la parole à face de la phase
iii puis on est arrivé à 24 heures plus
tôt à la même conclusion
une question honnêtement des quelques
heures la plupart des pays vont
s'enchaîner dans les prochaines semaines
mais c'est clair que symboliquement pour
un gouvernement comme justin trudeau qui
est sur la sellette depuis deux semaines
par les partis d'opposition n'aura pas
de dose vous n'êtes pas prêt c'est long
mais là soudainement à la même semaine
on approuve le vaccin on à l'époque de
les doses parmi les premiers pays au
monde à commencer à vacciner alors qu'on
ne produit même poste vaccin là alors
certainement que d'un côté pour du côté
politique l'a finie la session ottawa
sur ce plan le du moins le du vaccin en
position bien meilleure que ce qu'on
avait prévu que maintenant près de trois
semaines et je sais pu entendre le
monsieur de france veut plutôt à
l'émission mais il suit de ça à la trace
d'un succès à la trace martin pour que
dalle et sachets celle d'un dans les
lieux
la chaîne de froid ne soit jamais
interrompu veulent pas que des doses des
mauvaises euros soit donnée aux jeunes
monsieur legault aujourd'hui à envoyer a
quand même un signal que ça s'organise
est assez bien et est assez optimiste a
dit j'aimerais ça pouvoir avoir vacciné
la plus rapidement la cdu qu'on parle
d'un million et demi de doses là
d'ici la fin mars le semblait dire on va
peut-être être capable d avoir avant si
bien que les personnes qui vivent ch et
celle des les travailleurs de la santé
et les personnes qui vivent dans des
résidences pour personnes âgées pour
être vacciné quand même assez rapidement
au début de 2021 est là mais là ça va
donner un peu plus d'air et l'oeil a
commencé à parler de plans de
déconfinement alors on sentait ça c'est
certain optimisme dans les rangs du
gouvernement aujourd'hui on a parlé hier
martin monsieur foot gay bonne je vous
fais l'instant de l'opposition là dessus
on revient pas en conclusion avec ce
sujet
l'enjeu c'est celui d'avoir en place des
règles qui n'ont pas été respectées et
en plus de voir l'individu en question
affirmé que si c'était à refaire il le
referait
il n'a pas les mains libres n'a pas les
coudées franches pour occuper son poste
tout ce qu'on me demande
on demande au premier ministre de le
suspendre le temps qui règle ses
affaires ses auteurs et avis aux
observateurs attentifs de la cua
souvenirs québec il ya la pandémie mais
aussi l'éthique et je les invite pendant
le temps des fêtes aller prendre une
marche dans la neige et à réfléchir à
son avenir politique et l'opposition
exams en faire sortir le tweet de
monsieur legault en 2014 quand il disait
le refus de monsieur péladeau de se
soumettre à la décision du commissaire à
l'éthique et un thèse leadership pour
madame marois tam axa sa martias ça peut
faire mal
aujourd'hui est ce que cette histoire là
dans l'esprit du gouvernement est
terminée martin où on craint que ça
fasse des petits là que la boule de
neige grossit ce maïs une bonne la
question il est très bonne parce que
monsieur legault était pas la période de
questions aujourd'hui alors c'est le
leader parlementaire de remplacement qui
a pris tous les coups mais monsieur
legault a été questionné après il y
avait un point de presse plus tard il
dit ce qui se passe à la période de
questions c'est une chose mais ce que
les gens pensent et d'autres choses
alors clairement il fait le pari que ça
ne perd collera pas dans la population
m'ayant demain pas moins que c'est une
tâche sur son cheval blanc monsieur
legault a toujours été fait rue des tic
et il ya toujours eu des gens dans son
caucus qui était sa caution et il ya eu
une notamment l'ancien policier job chez
nos sonia lebel était sa caution éthique
dans ce cas-ci main et l'a écouté il n'y
a pas en respecter les règles et il y en
a peut-être même pas terminé parce que
la commissaire à l'éthique conclut que
si monsieur fils jaden ne règle pas ses
affaires prochainement elle va revenir
cuincy
les plus loin s'il ne vend pas ses
actions dans l'entreprise dont une de
vos actions privées les actions privées
donc c'est dit il ces peluches et la
vente
christian qu'en pensez vous de cette
histoire je pense que ça va encore
beaucoup la crédibilité en fait de la
commissaire des siècles ça a commencé
avec la sphère pierre paradis le sait
déjà le gall pierre paradis
à l'époque le gouvernement de potes qui
compte des recommandations de la
commissaire non il n'y à prendre quand
même réel que monsieur privé aucun
monsieur péladeau avait été confronté il
quand quelqu'un une entreprise
importante inquiets qui privée donc il
faut qu'ils avancent pas facile devant
ces entreprises d'eau mais moi ce qui
m'a frappé c'est le ton cavaliers en
fait avec lequel monsieur physique est
bonne traitée en peuple la commissaire à
l'éthique et recommandations mais comme
c'est l'habitude qui me semble que c'est
un non élu en fait qui est mandaté par
l'assemblée nationale
c'est difficile de s'imposer face à des
élus majeurs comme ce fut moi je suis
pas sûr du tout réhabiliter des traces
sur la politique mais le cas là comme ce
qu'elle est la crise du réel qui
allaient conclusions bon d'abord ça
paraît très mal pour pierre fitzgibbon
deux fois en deux en un mois ça paraît
pas très bien
et effectivement du côté du ton père
fait ce but n'était probablement pas
approprié la manière dont ils
s'adressent à la commissaire à l'éthique
en privé et en public il ya un espèce de
manque de différence qui est un peu
troublant en même temps c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait ajuster le code d'éthique pour
cette question là on peut mettre en
fiducie sans droit de regard des actions
publiques d'une entreprise mais départ
privé d'une entreprise on peux pas faut
absolument aller et ça c'est un peu
particulier des gens qui sont en affaire
qui se disent bien moi des petites
entreprises je peux pas vendre mais pas
comme ça je avoir la prochaine fois ça
sexy complexe je traversais dans
l'émission de gerald ça continue merci
merci et à bientôt